um let's see
what else we have going on let's go to
william from las vegas william welcome i
was just in las vegas not long ago
hello david uh were you here again
for another convention no no no i just
mean like a month ago
oh yes yeah all right uh so uh contrary
to your other caller you're far better
looking than that guy so just put that
out there oh good thank you i appreciate
that
uh i have two questions for you well
um
first how agile are the democrats going
to be
in the midterm elections given that we
we repeatedly have these issues where
maniacs shoot people up um
we never really solve the issue because
no one's able to find a common ground um
adding lethal elements into a school
seems like a banana's idea that's where
they want to go
i mean a few years back when a maniac
shut up my town there's been no progress
so how do you fight the apathy and the
you know futility of trying to to
progressively get
to a solution it's absolutely
infuriating and earlier this week after
the texas mass shooting we kind of i i
went through this cycle where
it's just it's like a rinse repeat mass
shooting everybody there's media
coverage everybody says we've got to do
something a few days go by then the
predominant voice becomes republican
saying whoa whoa we can't take away any
gun rights
then a few weeks or a couple months go
by and everybody kind of stops talking
about it and then there's another
shooting and it's just rinse repeat
here's my hope
i'm starting to see some polling some
not every poll but some polling that is
showing that as a result of
the forthcoming supreme court decision
on roe v wade and maybe because of the
obvious non-solutions that republicans
are proposing to the mass shooting issue
i'm starting to see some polling that's
starting to point in the direction of
november all of a sudden not looking so
bad for democrats normally it should be
a disaster for democrats joe biden just
won in 2020 you would expect democrats
to get crushed in the midterm
some new polling i'm seeing
genuinely seems to suggest that voters
are sick of what's going on and maybe
it actually won't be bad in november and
democrats might be able to get something
done it's very very cautious optimism
but it does seem like something might be
happening here
i hope so it is so frustrating uh
especially having seen that maniac shoot
up my town and there'll be nothing done
about it yeah it just happened every day
yeah uh so my last question if you if
you don't mind sure uh i'm making my
first trip to new york city later yeah
and i wondered in brooklyn area where's
a good place a great place if you're a
tourist to get a great bagel that
represents that city oh oh okay so
listen if you are in brooklyn my
recommendation
is go visit our friends you know i
actually don't know because it's been
it's been a couple months since i've
been there on smith street uh not too
far south of smith and atlantic okay
um there's a bagel cafe
on the west side of smith street it's
right on the corner at one point it was
called mocha bagels i think now it's
called smith street bagels maybe go in
there
tell them david pakman sent you they
know me in there and that is the place i
would highly recommend they'll make you
whatever you want if you say oh i want
uh you know roast beef on a french toast
bagel with maple syrup though i mean i
wouldn't recommend that by the way but
they'll make it they'll make you
whatever you want they're the nicest
guys in there
i think that's close to where i'm at i'm
in that boreham hill dumbo area where
i'm staying so i think that's your
blocks away from this you're blocks away
from this absolutely
beautiful david thank you so much for
accepting my call have a great one my
pleasure thank you
uh wow what what a big day of phone
calls here it's wild let's go next to
brian from phoenix arizona brian welcome
hey david can you hear me i can hear you
fine
awesome i was just uh seeing today uh my
one of my home state representatives
ruben gallego uh was sending off some
fiery tweets uh in the direction of ted
cruz and some other gop reps do you
think that that kind of
engagement uh online is
effective or um what you know would
actually lead to change or do you think
it's more performative i'm just
wondering what your opinion is about it
i think that um
our lawmakers don't make policy
based on arguments they get into on
twitter but i do think that the
performance can have some value because
i want to see elected officials who
genuinely seem to care and i've
interviewed ruben and he genuinely seems
to care so to the extent that it's
authentic i don't i don't care so much
about
oh is he really going to convince other
members of the house or senate one way
or the other on twitter no i don't think
he is but
he genuinely is passionate and i don't
mind seeing that on social media
awesome and then do you expect
related do you expect any uh federal gun
control legislation to happen after this
you know i i i don't i really if i'm
honest i don't
all right thank you that's it yeah all
right no problem yeah i i mean it's sad
but
i i just don't
let's go down to texas and speak to
asher from dallas asher go
asher from dallas you're on the air
and last chance
for asher
from dallas you are muted
i need you to unmute
or select your correct audio device i
can see that you're trying to talk but
no audio is coming through
that could be
an audio device issue
all right unfortunately no asher from
dallas experiencing
an issue a technical issue a technical
issue that's sad to uh sad to see
let's go next to doug from alabama doug
welcome
doug from alabama i can see that you
have muted yourself
all right my bad okay hey hey long time
listener david uh i just wanted to just
do like a brief rundown and just get
your opinion on something really fast
okay you know obviously we're in alabama
we got really lucky with uh doug jones a
few years ago because of the whole
fiasco
um
that's probably the most left person
that we've had
ever served because i mean we had
democrats before but they were really
like dixiecrats you know they weren't
really democrats
so um you know it's it's really sad uh
with the state of the the elections down
here um
the
current like democratic um
you know nominees for governor i'm
definitely gonna vote for whoever wins
um i really think that like walt maddox
should have ran again because he was he
was kind of more of like a biden kind of
centrist
democrat but he probably had the best
shot down here
um he only lost like 10 10 percentage
points last time but luckily it looks
like uh k ivy won so
she's still really really bad but the
the the alternative was even worse but i
want to get your opinion on something i
knew i pretty much know what your answer
was going to be because i've heard your
opinion before but
you're probably going to be mad at me
but i basically i actually voted in the
primary but
i wasn't you know i'm definitely going
to vote democrat in the uh in november
but i just chose for some reason my
friend told me i was an idiot for doing
it but i just decided to vote in the
republican primary just to get the the
least evil people to win because i know
that they're basically going to win in
november so i did even though mo brooks
was like the worst
probably the worst uh guy that we could
vote for that his uh katy brits even
worse um
in a lot of ways and you know obviously
trump doesn't like mo brooks so i kind
of just
did like a protest vote even though i
hate mo brooks and i don't want him to
win but i just i don't know
i just wanted your opinion on that i
know you i know you got a show to run
but i appreciate your uh doug i i i love
it i don't know what the question is but
we love phone calls from alabama and uh
please call in again okay i don't know
what the question is that was very
interesting but i'm just not sure what
the question is we're going to take a
very quick break just hold on because
we're going right back to the phone
lines in a moment